مع قدوم شهر رمضان توافد المواطنين
المغاربه على الاسواق لشراء متطلبات الشعر
من الفواكه الجافه والتمور والحبوب القاسم
المشترك بين الجميع الشكوى من الغلاء
تسوق مثلا بالف درهم خصك تسوق ب 3000 درهم
بطبيعه الحال غادي تحيد النص بالنسبه
للقفه ديال رمضان
هذا العام بالاخص استثنائي
بالباقي السنوات الفارطه بالنسبه للزياده
اللي كاينه في الاسعار على صعيد جميع
المواد الغذائيه من البيض اللي وصل لدرهم
ونص حتى للحب اللي ما بقاش قدرنا يحرس
مصطفى على الاعتناء بسلع شهر رمضان
ارضاء لزبناء محله في هذا السوق الشعبي في
العاصمه الرباط داعيا المغاربه الى تسوق
يتماشى مع القدره الشرائيه
والانسان كيما الناس
شحال هادي
مؤخرا خصوصا في هذه الاعوام الاخيره
يواصل المغاربه جولاتهم اليوميه للتسوق
الرمضاني
وسط رسائل تطمين من الحكومه بقرب تراجع
الاسعار يشتكي المواطرون المغاربه من موجه
غلاء يقولون انها غير مسبوقه تضرب الاسواق
المغربيه فيما يتحدث التجار عن وفره في
السلع وبان الاثمنه في المتناول هذا هو
المشهد في الاسواق الشعبيه المغربيه مع
اقتراب شهر رمضان عادل الزبير العربيه
الرباط